we've been given two paths right one is  you are your feelings it's the most  important thing however you feel on a  given day my favorite phrase right now  and I say that ironically is your truth  yeah like that's a that's not a thing  right  um so you are your feelings you are  whatever you feel in this moment and  we're gonna go that route the other side  is equally Insidious is if you have  feelings it's because you're weak and  you're a coward you suck it up grind it  and kill it and so for me it's a third  path which is you gotta feel this stuff  and then you have to go act right you  still got to go do what's right so it's  a context not an excuse and so go do  what you got to do even if you don't  feel like it  foreign